what's a movie you want to see what is  it you want to contribute what's the  movie that we have never seen because  you haven't made it  and make that movie  make the movie that it's the reason why  you're gonna be doing it the movies that  we're collecting in my head for all the  movies I saw I never saw them I saw a  flash of them I saw a movie that would  have a scene that would be the aesthetic  that I was looking for or they would  play a song in a movie and that would be  the kind of song that I would use and it  would have the kind of feeling that I'd  want a song to have in one of my movies  uh a character would be the kind of  character that I wanted to do a movie  about not all the other characters just  one character you know but usually like  I said it was a scene it was a a mood  for only a little bit or a section of  the movie but it was never the whole  enchilada